bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
corot projetons à la chine qu'on
reproche les états unis à la chine plus
exactement
les etats unis reprochent à la chine une
politiques d'opacité de secret puisque
vous savez qu'en fait cette épidémie a
commencé au mois de novembre 2019 à wall
et que des médecins chinois en décembre
à mai lancé des alertes
ils ont été au lieu que ces alertes
soient prises au sérieux ils ont été
convoqués par la police qui l'a ordonné
de ne pas ne plus répandre de fausses
nouvelles et ensuite les autorités
communistes de la province du hubei de
roanne autorisé à grand banquet
patriotique le 14 janvier avec quarante
mille personnes ce qui évidemment a
considérablement aidé à la propagation
de l'épidémie à travers toute la chine
puisque ensuite les gens sont allés dans
les différentes provinces de chine
alors c'est ces trois semaines où le
gouvernement chinois n'a pas combattu
l'épidémie où il ya eu aussi des
mensonges qui ont été données et ollier
par l'organisation mondiale de la santé
s'est enrichie d'inventis à l'om est ce
qu a menti au monde
en dix ans le 13 janvier que le virus
n'était pas transmissible d'homme à
homme alors que les médecins chinois de
l'hôpital de roanne avait déjà alerté
sur sa transmissibilité d'homme à homme
et donc c'est ça le principal reproche
qu aujourd'hui les américains font à la
chine alors ya aussi des théories qui
circulent au congrès américain qui
disent que que c'est une coïncidence
troublante de voir que le virus soit
venue de one parce que la théorie
aujourd'hui le dire
d'abord chinoise à dire le virus aurait
été contractée dans un marché l'ide de
chine à marcher huit ça veut dire où les
animaux sauvages et domestiques ce
s'entassent dans des cages vivent et
sont vendus vivent ils sont abattus sur
place
il ya beaucoup de liquide de différent
dans ces marchés c'est pas ça qu'on les
appelle humides et les et mécanismes et
c'est bizarre parce que ça aurait pu
survenir dans n'importe quelle autre
ville où il ya des marchés misent en
chine des centaines de marches et humide
et c'est précisément des as one
on a à la fois un grand laboratoire de
virologie et un autre laboratoire
d'infectiologie qui étudie précisément
ce sont des études qui étaient publics
étaient avérés qui étudie la
transmission du coronavirus des jours
sourit vers l'homme est alors la
question se pose et américains c'est n'y
at il pas une n'était pas eu un accident
de laboratoire les actions de
laboratoire arrive y compris dans les
laboratoires américains
renaud girard est qu'on a des preuves
concernant justement cette dernière
théorie ja lui même dans des journaux
chinois en février total très proche du
parti communiste c'était le global times
a tout à fait évoqué cette possibilité
d'un accident de laboratoire donc c'est
pas qu'elle sait quelque chose qui a
même été beaucoup discuté en chine
c'est tout à fait possible mais comme le
désastre est international il est pas du
tout il estime que le gouvernement
australien par exemple et demandé une
enquête internationale
c'est une enquête internationale par
exemple sous l'égide de l'onu avec les
meilleurs spécialistes du monde
une enquête indépendante à ce jour
personne ne pense qu'il ya malignité du
gouvernement chinois
sinon à personne n'accuse la chine
d'avoir voulu le répandre ce virus à
travers le monde mais on constate une
catastrophe mondiale et donc il n'est
pas anormal
demander une enquête mondiale ne serait
ce pour que ce genre de pandémie qui
s'est pas la première qui vient de chine
ne se reproduise pas et donc c'est pas
du tout anormal de demander une enquête
internationale et le gouvernement
chinois ne la veut pas et on ne comprend
pas pourquoi d'ailleurs parce que cette
enquête internationale ferait baisser la
tension sino américaines ça serait une
bonne chose car personne n'a gagné de
cette tension sino américaines dans le
monde ça rassurerait les pays européens
et ça empêcherait une autre pandémie
puisse se déclencher en tant que j'ai à
l'achat de voitures en tout cas là la
posture des autorités chinoises et de
démentir d'accuser washington justement
de proférer des mensonges a fait c'est
de demander et surtout il ya une opacité
s'ils voudront comprends pas pourquoi
une opacité chinoise
on se demande est ce que les chinois ont
quelque chose à cacher c'est un régime
si vous voulez qui a voulu s'ouvrir au
monde est un régime qui a une stratégie
de route de la soie la route de la soie
c'est quoi c est bien vous devez acheter
des produits chinois à travers le monde
vous devez ouvrir ou même vendre vos
propres infrastructures aux chinois il
ya aucun problème comme les chinois ont
acheté le port du pirée des principales
corps historique de l'europe continent
européen voilà donc c'est une pme ou des
pays européens aussi qui sont concernés
par ces routes de la soie hocine encore
tout à prouver qu'ils quittent donc
c'est une politique d'ouverture que
réclame qu est un machine très bien du
commerce elle dit que c'est c'est comme
comme disent les chinois c'est un win
win d'y tourner à profiter de cette
route de la soie et donc elle prône une
politique d'ouverture elle peut pas d'un
côté prôner une politique d'ouverture et
d'autre part brandi
la fermeture c'est à dire là ça me tue à
toute enquête internationale sur les
conditions de sécurité des laboratoires
de waele de la diplomatie américaine
pour dire que les conditions de sécurité
n'étaient pas assurés dans ce
laboratoire de biologie du wan ho qu'on
ne peut pas à la fois bondi à
l'ouverture commerciale et la fermeture
dans le domaine sanitaire alors qu'on a
une pandémie mondiale
merci renaud girard rappelle que vous
êtes un grand reporter pour le figaro
merci à vous